you thank you very much Ron Corleone
this really attractive woman is my
girlfriend Lucy Hello Lucy hi whoa
impressive handshake thanks my father
told me that a limp handshake was for
weak men and Communists he hated both
well done Tommy is that bacon on your
turkey leg they call it a Swanson
[Applause]
we are given the certificate who do you
think should speak first I think it
should be me and then you but if you
want it could be you and then me
or it could go me you me what do you
think how about just you thank you Ron
yes tomorrow the Parks and Rec
Department is receiving a commendation
at the Indiana state house for bringing
the Harvest Festival back
and although it's purely ceremonial it's
a huge deal for me to go to the state
house I couldn't care less about the
Commendation but Indianapolis is home to
Charles Mulligan's Steakhouse the best
damn Steakhouse in the damn State I have
taken a picture of every steak I've ever
eaten there June 2004 porterhouse medium
rare bearnaise sauce January 2000 they
call this one the enforcer February 96
the steak rib eye the whiskey lagavulin
16. the lady next to me a [ __ ]
specifically my ex-wife Tammy okay this
is this is the first time I ever went
there oh look at me just a kid
then maybe we should take a quick
two-hour sojourn to Dame gervin's
misshapen celebrity Castle it's where
Madame Tussaud sends all of its failed
wax figures and if you can figure out
who it is you get to take it home no
what's wrong with you grouchy pants I've
been fasting all day to save room for
Mulligans fasting's not healthy for you
Ron Leslie you need to understand we are
heading for the most special place on
earth when I'm done eating a Mulligan's
meal for weeks afterwards there are
flecks of meat in my mustache and I
refuse to clean it because every now and
then a piece of
oh I forgot to tell you Chris Traeger is
joining us for dinner tonight please
tell me he's meeting us at the
restaurant no we are picking him up damn
it woman
oh my God
they just forgot to unlock the door
that's all
Ron it looks like they're closed
some kind of health code violation
they just boarded her up like she was
some common Warehouse
I should have been here
what happened to the stakes that were in
there when they closed
do you think they got eaten why don't we
go back to my place and I'll fire up the
grill
you sure you're not expecting company or
something no
let me see Ron go back to my place and
make you some grub it'll be just as good
as it would have been here
okay
Ron would you like some salad since I am
not a rabbit no I do not try it sounds
good for you you got it
hmm delicious
Ron what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the Steak
oh there's no steak that's a healthier
option it's organically grown
huh you okay okay can you get us a cold
compress or something
this is a mistake why would you call it
that on your menu I don't know what to
tell you man
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait I worry what you just heard
was give me a lot of bacon and eggs what
I said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
[Music]
is it always like this I wouldn't know I
don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones Ron wait a
minute
hello beautiful
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt of the earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
stuffy graphs your Cheryl swoopses
but I will take a free breakfast buffet
Anytime Anyplace
[Music]
and I'll have the number eight that's a
party platter it serves 12 people I know
what I'm about son
and one number eight all right party
time I would suggest sticking around and
watching him eat it because it only
takes four minutes and it's pretty
easy it will not be necessary
I enjoy government functions like I
enjoy getting kicked in the nuggets with
a steel toe boot but this hotel always
serves bacon wrapped shrimp
my number one favorite food wrapped
around my number three favorite food I
go to a banquet and honor those Somali
pirates if they serve bacon wrapped
shrimp excuse me
hey table 12 can I get a what what wow
thank you I mean and you look stunning
but Leslie
wow I was going for a while you got it I
was told it was Black Tie I like your
hairdo Leslie thank you Ron it's just
like my brothers he's an officer in the
Air Force
bacon wrapped shrimp oh thanks I'm okay
I want I wasn't offering
this came out
yeah
I am starving I haven't had lunch since
yesterday so I'm gonna head over to
Callahan's oh no no don't go there they
totally skimp on pickles let me go to
big head Joe's for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food trust me they have one
that's called the meat tornado
literally killed the guy last year
you had made me tornado
song was a six round pick Kali was the
fourth round Indianapolis Colts know how
to draft so well they really do
Andy this was delicious it's awesome huh
it's a whole new meat delivery system
thank you son what do you say we go out
to the parking lot run a few pass plays
to burn off the calories you are an
Unstoppable good idea machine
I like Andy I'm surrounded by a lot of
women in this department
and that includes the men
up
close corner
and he made up
foreign
song what up my man are you kidding me
top of the morning everyone I brought
some burgers and fries
eat up the protein soaks up the sugar
[Music]
first you take the cow to The Killing
Floor
Hey Ron thanks for coming man of course
this bowling alley has my favorite
restaurant in Pawnee
really you're not scared to eat here
when I eat it is the food that is scared
would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
I I don't think I can give you any more
I want one
I'm gonna get 12 eggs and part of a dead
animal dealer's Choice please and thank
you what a gorgeous herbaceous medley
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats salad is traditionally the
first course at a wedding there's a
gerbil marrying a rabbit
I'm in charge of food for the wedding so
I brought in pawnee's three best
Caterers and a panel of experts Chris
loves vegetables Ron loves meat and Tom
considers himself a foodie which
apparently means taking Instagrams of
food instead of eating it I said of
course I remember you you're Chastity
right
Leslie even though I didn't invite you
you came here anyway I respect that
because you made a choice as a free
American
what are you eating I call this Turf and
turf it's a 16 ounce T-Bone and a 24
ounce Porter House also Whiskey and a
cigar I'm going to consume all of this
at the same time because I am a free
American the cigars inside sir
fine I will smoke the entire thing
outside even though it is bad for me I
am going to do it